der große hans streit hin gibt es jetzt
hier bei bild live und auf der einen
seite sozusagen begrüßt sich georg wurth
den chef des deutschen handballbundes
und auf der anderen seite auf der
gegenseite den bundesvorsitzenden
stellvertretenden bundesvorsitzenden
gewerkschaft der polizei die massiv in
beiden herzlich willkommen beim wäre
schönen guten morgen hat uns das
wirklich gerade noch gefehlt die
legalisierung von hanf r chef
na ja es wäre es interessant dass dieses
thema jetzt so weit aufgemacht wird ob
die sondierungsgespräche tatsächlich das
hauptthema haben das ist sehr fraglich
sagt es aber heißt es gibt in der frage
seit jahren unterschiedliche
auffassungen muss es da nicht unruhig
diskutieren und ist schon etwas komisch
dass man diese teilweise sehr aggressive
debatte erlebt wie ihr geschäft mit dem
thema seit jahren als die wirtschaft der
polizei und auch als sein dass uns
beraten von verklärten insofern muss man
da sagt und mit geld umgehen wir machen
das mindestens und sagen dass
legalisierung nach unserer auffassung
nicht dass die mitte ist aber da gibt es
wie gesagt auch andere ist als prozessor
hersteller einmal ap nachfrage an sie
welche gefahren sehen sie denn da
konkret
das ist wenn man der auffassung welche
fach nur dass das dann zu sagen haben
auf einer fachveranstaltung 2015 in
berlin zum beispiel mit der den weg
ascheberger mensch gesprochen und andere
fachleute aus anderen europäischen
ländern so du mit dem professor lothar
weinert thomas muss erst der fachliche
leiter der ärzten und jugendklinik in
hamburg und die die wassertreter vor vor
den freunden von jahrelang canalis
gebrauch das kann man natürlich auch
wieder hinterfragen hier nehmen das aber
zum anlass zumindest diese frage zu
stellen zweite frage ist welche
auswirkungen hat das geht der
gesundheitlich in frage die natürlich
nicht er sein hauptinteresse steht als
gdp aber als gesellschaft behandelt
werden muss ist die frage ob wir nehmen
den gehoben die wir haben alkohol
nikotin und anderen auch noch eine weite
so geben die auch einfluss auf die
qualität und einfluss auf den
straßenverkehr wurde die polizei also
die fachleute dort haben große sorgen
wenn es um die legalisierung von
cannabis geht nehmen sie diese sorgen
nicht ernst
diesmal kann aber es ist keine harmlose
substanz das gras gibt risiken vor denen
waren wir auch regelmäßig aber die
argumentation der polizei basiert darauf
dass sie sagen es gibt jetzt eigentlich
gar kein cannabis ja wir machen neues
fass auf wir bringen und neue droge auf
dem markt neben alkohol und tabak und
dass er nicht der fall wir haben
millionen konsumenten wir verbrauchen
paar hundert tonnen cannabis produkte im
jahr das milliarden umsatz den wir da
organisierten kriminellen zum teil zur
verfügung stellen anstatt das vermutlich
zu regulieren auch im sinne des
gesundheitsschutzes dass da auch eine
gewisse kontrolle qualitätskontrolle
verbraucherschutz stattfindet ich kann
das schwer nachvollziehen und diese
argumentation mit der gefährlichkeit
das vergleicht ja nie mit alkohol und
anderen riskanten dingen die auch nicht
verboten sind in deutschland gerade wenn
man nur auf cannabis guckt muss man
sagen sicherheit gepriesen aber im
vergleich zu alkohol sind die geringer
auf jeden fall alkohol und tabak
zusammen fordern über 100.000 todesopfer
im jahr in deutschland cannabis null
tote mal als ein beispiel es gibt auch
andere gesundheitliche bereiche wo mit
sicherheit alkohol die gefährliche
substanz ist und kein mensch denkt
drüber nach alkohol zu verbieten
insofern finde ich dass jetzt endlich
ein bisschen klingt für mich nach
doppelmoral
immer wieder heißt es aber auch kann man
damit nicht auch junge menschen zu den
drogen bekommen zur zur hand bekommen
die davor als es illegal war oder noch
ist kann ich darüber nachgedacht haben
also die frage auch an sie befürchten
sie nicht dass dann immer mehr menschen
dann hanf konsumieren werden einmal wenn
es dann legal ist ja gerade die jungen
menschen befürchtet das nicht weil die
lassen sich sowieso nicht abschreckend
von der position von der repression da
steht ja auf der anderen seite der reiz
des verbotenen dagegen sozusagen das
eher spannend macht in der jugend wo man
sich von der elterngeneration abgrenzen
will von daher das sehen wir auch in den
anderen ländern die jetzt legalisiert
haben kanada usa da gibt es leichte
zunahme des konsums aber nicht bei
jugendlichen nicht bei den risikogruppen
um die es eigentlich geht sondern eher
bei älteren für die dann doch vielleicht
die repression auch eine gewisse
hemmschwelle ist oder die einfach keine
leute kennen die mal eben was besorgen
können im gegensatz zu jugendlichen da
haben wir dann bei den 40 50 jährigen
aufwärts bei den grauhaarigen mal ein
paar leute die probieren die vorher
nicht probiert haben aber dass keine
risikogruppe ich fange ich vor der
arbeit an zu kippen
insofern meinen das risiko sehe ich
nicht sondern ich sehe er die gefahr
dass konsumenten jetzt inklusive
jugendlichen so zu sagen da vergiftet
werden auf dem markt weil da eben
wirklich problematische sachen unterwegs
sind gestrecktes marihuana mit vier
gefährlichen inhaltsstoffen die so nicht
nötig werden das verwirrt sagt nun ja ja
cannabis da lauern schon auch gefahren
aber mit gesetzen kann man die jungen
leute zumindest sowieso nicht mehr
abschrecken mit verboten die machen das
sowieso haben sie letztlich hat die
polizei haben die behörden hat die
politik herrn wird jetzt die besten
argumente dadurch geliefert dass man das
nicht durchgesetzt hat vorher dass
cannabis illegal sind denn irgendwas ist
denn irgendwann muss es ja haben dass
heute so viele cannabis legalisieren
obwohl es eben nicht legal ist
daher ist er wusste dazu sagen was sie
wohnten sorgt da hab ich nicht wieso hat
ist es so dass wir natürlich canales
rahmen oder marian oder andere produkte
die frage ist nur wann doch alle
zusätzlich ruge legalisiert und die
frage muss sich einfach muss ich ja
verstehen auch in holland ist es so dass
dort aufgrund eines berichts der
süddeutschen zeitung die er durchaus
eine zeitung das thema zitieren kann und
gesagt wird dass man dort die dänische
regierung jetzt auch wieder respektive
maßnahmen durchführt weil deren profiten
dadurch gemacht wird die man milliarden
profite ort die kriminalität auf den
plan rufen also insofern hat die wir vor
jahren als gdp wir sind der
mitgliederorganisationen mit 200.000
mitgliedern mit fachleuten aus der
polizei übrigen mehr kriminalermittler
als in anderen organisationen die das
auch fordern insofern muss man sich
damit auseinandersetzen was wie man
damit bewirken die zweite frage ist wir
brauchen eine einheitliche grenze es
kann sein dass in einigen ländern 30 km
frei geworden sind in anderen ländern
nur sechs gramm freigabe des notwendigen
die klare rechtliche regelung und da
muss man in der politik überreden
insgesamt über damit umgeht und da
erwarten wir dass die unterschiedlichen
auffassung der fachleute auch ernst
genommen werden sprich auch nochmal den
straßen fertig ich selber brauche jahre
lang im bereich der
beschaffungskriminalität und der
straßenkriminalität bleiben kommissariat
immer shrek tätig da war schlosspark
drogen vertickt und wurde natürlich auch
geraucht und da kann man feststellen
dass gerade die kombination zwischen
cannabisprodukten major produkten
handelsprodukten alkohol und den
alterversorgung dass die leute ein
trikots sind und das ist ein problem
also man haben sicherlich richtig aber
deswegen umso wichtiger noch mal meine
frage sie haben doch also sie nicht
persönlich ja weil die behörden die
polizei hat doch herrn wurde jetzt die
besten argumente dafür geliefert wenn
eben bestehendes recht nicht offenbar
ausreichend durchgesetzt wurde bisher
also wenn herr wird jetzt heute sagen
kann naja kommt also die leute halten
sich doch sowieso nicht an die regeln
mittlerweile keine konsumiert doch
sowieso jeder cannabis zu kommen was
auch freigeben
naja dann könnten sie das verbrauchen
mit zum beispiel diebstählen oder mit
anderen massnahmen gefahr durch beruf
über die ampeln weil sie sich daran
halten legalisieren das ohne dass der
debatte habe ich mich nicht anders sagt
dass man muss klare rechtliche
regelungen dafür aber die frage ist wie
man eine droge zusätzlich noch in
kriminalisieren beziehungsweise man kann
darüber autos tätigkeiten recht reden
das sind debatte wo sich ja auch
fachleute darüber austauschen wie er
sage als ep man muss sich mit dem thema
intensiv auseinandersetzen es gibt wohl
konto argumente wir sind nicht
diejenigen die so massiv und aggressiv
vorgehen wie es andere leute gegen die
auffassung machen dass man sich das
angucken muss ist die jahrelange debatte
und wir sind mal gespannt wie die
patriots weitergeht
ich musste noch einmal fangen ist ein
bisschen wie vor die nachteile abgewogen
aber was finden sie eigentlich sie ganz
bei sinnen ist so toll an cannabis es
geht überhaupt nicht darum dass cannabis
toll ist
nicht wirklich sagen cannabis rettet die
welt gibt es keine kriege mehr wenn alle
kiffen aber darum geht es nicht ja ich
kenne auch leute die probleme haben ich
kenne auch leute bei denen diese
berühmte psychose ausgelöst worden ist
ja das gibt es tatsächlich auch wenn
sehr selten insofern es geht tut sich
auch darum künftige prävention zu machen
dafür zu sorgen dass möglichst wenig
jugendliche anfangen damit jedenfalls
nicht so früh und nicht so viel und so
weiter die risiken minimieren das
überhaupt nicht das thema sondern die
frage ist er zu sehen wir haben dieses
gesellschaftliche phänomen wir haben die
polizeimaßnahmen haben überhaupt keinen
erfolg obwohl wir von rekord zu rekord
eilende sozusagen was die strafverfahren
angeht die repressionen wurde immer
schlimmer in deutschland der
verfolgungsdruck für an freunde wird
immer schlimmer ohne dass das irgendwie
den konsum reduziert es grandios
erfolglos diese ganze geschichte
und es ist auch viel sinnvoller den
markt zu regulieren und zu sagen okay
wir sorgen dafür dass wir eine
qualitätskontrolle haben das für den
jugendschutz haben das nicht an
jugendliche verkauft wird denn in
lizensierten fachgeschäften kann man das
kontrollieren im gegensatz zum
schwarzmarkt und auch im gegensatz zu
alkohol in deutschland post an jeder
ecke verkauft wird auch nicht in ordnung
ja so fachgeschäfte für erwachsene geben
da habe ich viel mehr überblickt und das
geht nicht darum dass er das mehr leute
konsumieren sollen sondern dass wir es
insgesamt vernünftiger machen dass wir
steuern einnehmen auf cannabis mit denen
wir vernünftige prävention bezahlen
können die wirksamer ist als eben diese
ganze dieses ganze polizei hamsterrad
wir streiten hier heute vormittag bei
bild live über eine mögliche
legalisierung von cannabis grund dafür
anlass für diesen streit die aktuellen
ampel gespräche und die vermutung dass
man sich dort in dieser ampel ganz
besonders schnell auf genau dieses thema
einigen könnte nämlich auf die
legalisierung von cannabis
abschlussfrage ganz schnell an sie beide
nur ja oder nein herr wird rechnet sie
damit dass das tatsächlich kommt dass
die ampel sich darauf einigen wird da
ich auch schon herr schäfer
erhofft ich hoffe ich und ich bin
interessiert daran dass todd mit
eingebunden werden also in suchen wir
gucken was rauskommt
danke ihnen für diesen cannabis streit
heute vormittag hierbei bild live
[Musik]